Barn away the best prize that Life
offers is the chance to work hard at
work worth doing true tremendous dignity
tremendous satisfaction in being tired
from actually having worked hard it's a
good thing and you know it can be
something as silly as I remember I was a
little kid barely old enough to reach
the end of the middle bar on the push
lawnmower meaning the handle reached up
to an adult and I was the lookout
standing in front of it in the middle
but I felt like I mowed the grass
because my dad drugged me along with
while he was doing it and then when we
finished we'd always you know this it's
maybe a guy thing or maybe it's a
redneck thing I don't know but we had
always stand out in the street and look
at the finished yard after everything
was edged and raked and trimmed and the
and the mulch was weeded and all that
stuff right the whole thing and we stand
out there and just take a moment and
just say hey job well done
it could be something as simple as that
I think it's why I like the pressure
wash because it just you can see that
you're making progress you know and
you're tired when you're done at least I
am at my age so I'm you know it doesn't
matter what it is it can be something
really simple like that or it can be
something very lofty and big and
carrying on I spoke for the entire day
on Friday to the entree leadership
master series on family business some
brand new curriculum on successfully
transitioning family businesses and
successfully operating family businesses
and the data that we found as we've
researched that and interviewed hundreds
and hundreds of companies that do a
great job and we personally walked in it
ourselves with our family coming into
Remzi solutions and so we shared all
that I was on stage all day on Friday
and when I got home I was tired because
speaking will speaking will drain you
especially if you're half exciting and
you're not asleep yourself right so it
was it was a lot done that in a while
and spoke the entire day you know I
usually do a couple hours here a couple
hours there or something but that was a
long one it was fun there's two brand
new materials energizing to me to teach
it and for them to hear it
it's tiring far and away the best prize
that Life offers is the chance to work
hard at work worth doing proverbs 13 4
says the soul of the sluggard craves and
gets nothing
while the soul of the diligent is richly
supplied the diligent prosper diligence
is excellence over time and be excellent
for a moment or you can be not excellent
over time but if you're excellent over
time that's what we would call diligence
and the diligent people prospering
that's what the Bible says and so that
means that if you are more diligent than
someone else you should have prospered
more than someone else and that is fair
it's just not fair that so-and-so makes
more than so-and-so yes it is it's
completely fair I'm not as pretty or as
smart and hasn't worked as many hours as
some other people that are prettier than
me smarter than me and has worked more
hours than I have and they have more
than I have as a result and I'm not mad
at them about that and a bunch of you
need to stop your dadgum jealous envious
stuff itself out here or you're jealous
of everybody else and you're envious of
everybody else instead of tearing down
success once you get your butt in gear
and go be one instead of trying to tear
down everybody else the diligent prosper
the soul of the sluggard sluggard that's
just such a good word the sluggard it's
other words we don't use anymore if you
just walked out someone said your
sluggard I've had people that worked
here there were sluggards they're not
here anymore the soul of a sluggard
craves and gets nothing
and you know if you sit on your butt and
you have all the you know all the
reality shows memorized and you know
every single thing about every sports
team and you don't play on any of them
and none of them pay you and you're not
any good at your job and then you demand
because you're entitled to a fair wage
you're not entitled to nothing twerp
you're a sluggard that's even better
than twerp sluggard maybe my new word
I'm gonna get stuck on that